my name is Neela Chowdhury and I'm
senior manager for the US for ecology it
was ten times better than I ever
imagined so much energy from everybody I
felt like people really wanted to be
here they were like hungry for it about
my stuff I love seeing how many junior
level people that were at the event
people who've been in recruitment a
couple months a few weeks and they were
so excited and you tell that they wanted
to be in an environment where they're
around other like experienced intruders
and being able to ask questions but they
don't feel comfortable in the management
so I love it
I feel let our industry get such a bad
rap it's sort of like if you have a job
oh no one wants you don't want to talk
about it you're embarrassed to mention
you're feeling weird to promote
ourselves for their clients would be
like are you taking the piss and pay you
too much we need a place where we can
come together be excited and part of
what we do and I just need to have that
our industry so you have hit the nail on
the head
I'm jealous and I wish I'd thought of it
first
you